what we just said we're focusing
aggressively on
the texas border and countries that we
think have to be watched very very
carefully because
you have some very very highly infected
countries
outside of our borders i've spoken with
governor
abbott terrific gentleman and i can
report that over 3
300 federal personnel on the ground in
texas we've
given them a tremendous amount amount of
extra help including doctors
nurses front line people we've supplied
texas with more than 2.5 million gloves
800 000 goggles 337
000 surgical gowns 1.8 million surgical
masks
1.36 million n95 respirators and half a
million
kn 90 masks beginning this week texas
hospitals will receive
500 cases of rem de severe
which has proven very effective enough
to treat 3200 patients
in addition to the cross-border spread
the stage of the pandemic is being
fueled by younger americans who
generally have little risk of being
seriously harmed by the disease
but can spread the disease we need all
americans to be conscious about their
actions and to exercise
extreme vigilance i trust all americans
to do the right thing but we strongly
advise everyone
to especially especially focus
on maintaining a social distance
maintaining
rigorous hygiene avoid large gatherings
and crowded indoor bars
and wear masks when appropriate we also
strongly urge citizens to take extra
precautions to shield those
at highest risk which are in most cases
in many cases the elderly especially the
elderly with
medical problems such as heart or
diabetes
but you want to shield them and you want
to guard them and you want to protect
them from the virus especially
especially those that are really
targeted almost targeted you could say
by this horrible
horrible plague this horrible epidemic
pandemic
america will develop a vaccine very soon
and we will defeat the virus we will
have it delivered in record time
as our visit here demonstrates and i
want to thank all of the people and
representatives from the great state
of north carolina there's a great is a
great place
it's a phenomenal place and uh
we've had so many great meetings and
such a great time
i want to drive and to the drive and
tenacity of
your representatives and your
politicians has been incredible
when they call i'm there when they call
most of them many of them are sitting
here right now
i will always answer their call so thank
you very much i appreciate you being
here with us and
let's get on to a few questions
tremendous
progress has been made and it's been
made rapidly and it's been made in areas
that
nothing like that has taken place before
so please thank you very much
[Applause]
is today's event about giving americans
uh
hope a sense of optimism is that what
you're trying to well i think
i think so but you know there would be
not that same kind of hope if we weren't
doing so well
where uh you know before just before i
left the white house in the oval office
we had a meeting with our
doctors scientists some others and
they're they're making tremendous broad
progress with respect to uh therapeutics
i can tell you therapeutically i think
over the next couple of weeks we'll have
some really very good things to say
uh we're just having great answers so it
is about that
and it's also the vaccine that we
discussed today at
even greater length is just coming along
really well and it's not just one
company as many companies have had
tremendous progress so that'll be
announced over the next very short
period
well i heard very positive things but by
the end of the year we think we're in
very good shape to be doing that by the
end of this year we're going to
in terms of the vaccine i think in terms
of therapeutics even sooner than that
therapeutics meaning you go and you give
somebody whether it's transfusion or
shots or whatever it may be
and they heal and they heal quickly so
we've had tremendous
progress we already have if you look at
rem disappear
and you look at some of the other things
but we'll have we'll
have some announcements on that over the
next two weeks yeah it is hope but it's
only hope because we've gotten
such incredible results scientifically
yeah
you did talk with russian president
vladimir putin and
i wanted to ask if you did bring up the
reports
of russia having bounties on our
soldiers and
we don't talk about what we discussed
but we had plenty of discussion
and i think it was very productive
please
larry cutlow earlier today said that the
v-shaped recovery is showing signs of
moderating
do you think given what we're seeing
with the increase in cases that the
recovery could be in jeopardy at all
economically
i don't think so i think the recovery
has been very strong we've set record
job numbers we've set record numbers
whether it's a prv or a little bit less
than that
i think it's going to be very good if
therapeutically we
come up with some answers very quickly
which i think we will
then you're going to have a tremendous
recovery uh
likewise with the vaccines if you do
that by the end of the year that's ahead
of schedule substantially ahead of
schedule
and it's ahead of anything that's ever
taken place in terms of vaccines before
so i think if those things happen if
just one of those events happen
you'll go right back into that v and i
think you're probably in the v
anyway i really do believe a lot of the
governors
should be opening up states that they're
not opening
and we'll see what happens with them but
a lot will have to do with the fact that
therapeutically i think you're gonna
have some great answers vaccine wise
likewise yeah please go ahead in the
back i'm asking zachary ames from the
raleigh news and observer
um now that you've cancelled the
jacksonville portion of the rnc
do you think governor cooper made the
right choice
in charlotte well we're actually coming
to
north carolina as you know we're having
a very major i guess that would be the
nomination night
so that's monday it'll be monday they're
going to be here
and the rest will do in a different form
we could have
done it many different ways but i think
we did the right thing and
uh i'm really happy that we're going to
be having a piece of it
at least and a very important piece in
north carolina yes please
go ahead mr president your poll numbers
suffered in recent months because of
your handling on this pandemic you're
here now today
what's your plan going forward to prove
to americans that you're the right
person
i think the poll numbers are very good
uh the poll numbers we have are very
good we're leading in north carolina
we're leading in pennsylvania we're
leading in arizona our numbers
we're leading in arizona we're leading
nicely in florida
i think our poll numbers are very good
we're leading substantially in georgia
i mean we get a lot of suppression polls
we get a lot of fake polls just like we
have fake news i mean it's a terrible
thing
when you look at it but i had the same
thing four years ago i was losing
everywhere i had poll numbers why i
wasn't going to win any state and i
ended up winning every one of them
you know the swing states i wasn't going
to win any of them and i won all of them
and i have the same thing this year this
year they
have it even closer they have it closer
but it's the same
suppression type polls we have polls
that show me leading
in almost every swing state and
substantially
in other states by even more than a 1 in
16.
when you look at florida as an example
you have thousands of boat out about
boats out of the ocean out on the
intercoastal
you look at other states where likewise
you have thousands of
boats and they're all waving the trump
sign
trump pence sign and they're so proud
thousands and thousands you've seen it
where you have bikers for trump with uh
lines that are miles long on highways
going along
on weekends i think there's more spirit
now
than there's ever been for my campaign
and that includes 2016 where obviously
there was great enthusiasm great spirit
we had great spirit
i think there's more today because what
we've done nobody's ever done before
nobody has ever rebuilt the military
cut taxes the most in our history
created the greatest economy we've ever
had
cut regulations at a level that nobody's
ever done
and all of these different things the va
we got va choice
we got va everything for
the va right now they had a 91 approval
rating
in a recent poll i was just speaking to
the secretary 91 percent in the via
that's never happened before
uh i think when people see all that
we've done even space force
we created a force a actual
you know army navy air force marines
right it's it's pretty
amazing coast guard and now space force
that hasn't happened in 75 years uh what
we've done
working with some of those warriors over
there by the way but what we've done
has never been done if you look at
alaska with anwr one of the bill
perhaps the biggest drilling site in the
world even ronald reagan
and bush and clint everybody wanted to
get it done i got it done anwar and
alaska
probably or possibly the biggest
drilling site in the world
now what we've done has been incredible
recently
it looked like the energy business was
going to be
a catastrophe we were number one in the
world and then we had the pandemic and
nobody was using energy nobody was
driving in automobiles
no gasoline and by the way gasoline
prices for everyone are very very low
in many cases less than two dollars
that's pretty incredible
and i saved the energy business i got
russia and i got saudi arabia
on the phone and they cut way back and
we're now at
40 and plus a barrel
and we're saving tens of millions of
jobs and energy
with the number one in energy in the
world so with all that we've done
we made and brought this country to the
greatest point in its history
we never had an economy like we had
prior to the china
plague or china virus coming in we never
had numbers like
it we are going to have them again and
everyone knows i'm going to rebuild it
i had to close it up we saved millions
of lives by closing it if we didn't
close it you would have seen numbers
that would have been
uh 15 times what you have right now one
death is too much
but it would have been 10 to 15 times
maybe more than that what you have
we closed this greatest economy ever far
bigger than china better than china
china was having by the way the worst
year they had in 67 years tariffs
they paid us tens of billions of dollars
the worst year they've had think of it
in 67 years we were having the best year
we've ever had
i had to close it and now we're
reopening it and next year we'll be
stronger
it'll be the strongest year so far it'll
be better even than last year
okay thank you very much i'll be heading
back and i'll see you back at the white
house
thank you very much we're going to take
an additional tour
of the facility with your great leaders
thank you very much to the people of
north carolina we love being here thank
you
all right
gentlemen please welcome the president
of the united states
donald j trump
manufacture and deliver a vaccine in
record time and that's what it is in
record time